hi this is Mario with Mario's math
tutoring coming truth another math video
to help you boost your score in your
math class improve your understanding
and hopefully make learning math a lot
less stressful so in this video we're
gonna talk about is how to take
repeating decimals and change them into
fractions using geometric series okay so
we're gonna look at an example in this
particular example is a little bit more
challenging some of the examples and you
may have seen in your book but here
we've got point zero eight three
repeating and notice it's just the three
that's repeating and what students
sometimes get confused by is what do I
do with the point zero eight right so
what you want to do is you want to just
separate out the point zero eight for a
moment so just write this as point zero
eight and what we're really interested
in here is 0.0 0.3 three three okay this
is the next term is going to be point
zero zero zero three plus point zero
zero zero zero three dot dot dot okay so
you can see this is a series because
we're adding the terms together we're
just going to ignore this point we'll
eat for a moment we're just going to
work with this part right here and then
we'll add it in at the very end so what
you can see is that each time what are
we doing to get to the next term well
we're multiplying by point one okay
point one and the next term same thing
we're multiplying by point one so
whenever you move that decimal point you
know one to the left that's like
dividing by ten that's 1/10 which is 0.1
and this point one is the r-value that's
the ratio okay in a geometric series so
since this is going on forever okay it's
an infinite geometric series and since
the ratio is in between negative one and
one okay we know this is going to
converge it's going to get smaller and
smaller it's going to approach zero we
can add up all these terms using the
infinite geometric series of K of the
sum formula okay which is a 1 over 1
minus R right so the first term is point
zero zero three so point zero zero three
over one minus point one that's our
ratio so if we simplify this we get
point zero zero three over
okay 0.9 now you can see this is still
decimals here we want to convert this
into a fraction so let's see if we can
get rid of these decimals let's multiply
the top and bottom by a thousand okay
and so what that converts to is it's
going to be three because we're moving
the decimal three places and this one
we're going to be moving it three places
so that comes to three over 900 which
equals one over 300 okay but we have to
add on the point zero eight now point
zero eight is really eat hundredths okay
so we have to add this to eat one
hundredths okay and if we multiply the
numerator and denominator by three
because we're trying to get common
denominators you can see we get 24 over
300 plus one over 300 this is coming out
225 over 300 now we can reduce it down
even further
we know that 25 goes into 300 how many
times twelve times so this is going to
be 1/12 now what I recommend doing is
just checking just go to your calculator
and just see so 1 divided by 12 is 0.08
3 3 3 3 3 repeating so you know you've
got the right answer so 1/12 is our
rational you know expression here for
0.2 0.3 repeating okay so we're changing
from a repeating decimal to a fraction
using geometric series so if you're
enjoying these videos subscribe to the
channel check out some of my past videos
and stay tuned I've got more videos like
these coming for you so I'll see you in
the next video